we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors blinkist is the app that helps
you become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman so we've been talking quite
a bit over the last four years but in
particular in the period leading up to
the election and then since the election
when we've seen
not 75 million people as some
in the house of representatives have
been claiming today but
certainly tens of millions of people
fall for
the false belief that the 2020
presidential election was somehow
stolen from donald trump even though
donald trump was the rightful winner
it's
uh disheartening and concerning and
scary that so many people have fallen
for that
and in thinking about how that came to
be um
the idea of a shared psychosis is
important to
think about and there's a very
interesting article in scientific
american
which we're going to link to on our
youtube channel which summarizes
some of dr bandy xle's views
on what moved donald trump's followers
to fall collectively for these delusions
and to then also become violent and
behave destructively as we saw
on january 6 during the trump riot in
washington dc
and the the answers are widespread and
there are many overlaps between what dr
lee says who's been a guest on this
program by the way
and what we talked about about magical
thinking
several weeks ago and when bandy lee was
asked
in this interview in scientific america
american
what attracts people to trump dr lee
says
that there are two major emotional
drives there's narcissistic symbiosis
and then there's the idea of shared
psychosis now
narcissistic symbiosis we've sort of
talked about before
and that is described as the
developmental
wounds that make the leader follower
relationship attractive to both
the leader trump is hungry for people to
worship him
essentially because he lacks self-worth
and we know this to be true we know
about trump's relationship with his
father
and how uh you know the relationship
between fred trump and donald trump is
not that different
than the the relationship we observe
between trump and his children in
particular don jr who seems also
desperate
for his father's adulation when trump
doesn't really seem to care that much
uh about his children at least in the
sort of traditional ways as we've seen
publicly um that we understand that
that's that's something that uh
we've we've identified um relatively
early
shared psychosis is very interesting
because what we are essentially talking
about is
a national level delusion that is
plaguing
tens of millions of people again not 75
million not all 75 million trump voters
are are part of this
but certainly we would look at the polls
and you know when 60 percent of trump
voters believed up until weeks ago
that it is trump who would be
inaugurated in a week not joe biden
it certainly afflicts many of them and
that
is as again referred to by dr bandy lee
the infectiousness of symptoms that go
beyond
group psychology we've talked for a long
time about
how did those tea party people end up
supporting in 2010
candidates who were running on policies
that weren't good for them
running on low taxes for the rich which
these people were never going to be rich
we understand the group psychology
aspect pretty well
jonathan height who i've interviewed has
talked about that we understand that
the uh um when we talk about shared
psychosis as dr
bandy lee refers to it the process is
you put in an influential position
somebody
who is afflicted by this psychosis now
we don't have to guess
does trump believe the delusions or does
he repeat them
even though he doesn't believe them it
doesn't matter the point is
he repeats them and he's in a position
of power and
then you can see it spread
through the population through either an
emotional bond
that trump's followers believe they have
with him or
the heightening of people already
predisposed to conspiratorial thinking
or paranoia or people with a propensity
for violence and that
fully describes the people that ended up
violently storming the capital last week
so let's go through again
all of the different elements that exist
here
you start with a group of followers of
trump that on average is more
predisposed to violence we know that
we know that uh and we know that from
looking at the um
brain differences essentially between
reactionary right wingers and other
groups we know that there's more of a
predisposition to violence there
there's more paranoia there's more fear
there's more belief that other people
are out to get you and on and on and on
so you start with that group now
many of those people even though they
hold those beliefs they're not going to
fall for the shared psychosis they're
not going to believe the delusions
and they are not actually going to go to
the capitol and commit violent acts
but then you take that group that larger
group that just is
slightly more predisposed to violence
more predisposed to conspiratorial and
paranoid thinking
and then you do a two-month campaign
where the leader
the narcissistic leader repeats repeats
repeats these delusions about it was
stolen
and there were massive dumps of votes
and uh this happened in pennsylvania and
in michigan the watchers weren't allowed
to see and then in georgia this right
you repeat it repeat it you do two
months
to that group and you're going to take
some sub section of those
who are going to be infected for lack of
a better term by these ideas that are
being spread by trump of the theft of
the election
and then you get to january 6th where
you have
a group broadly speaking more
predisposed to conspiratorial thinking
uh and also more predisposed to violence
not all of them willing to do it in real
life and for two months you hammer
hammer hammer on them and then you start
using terms like
we've got a fight and you literally say
we're going to go
down to pennsylvania down pennsylvania
avenue to the capitol
uh and that's how you get what we got
last week
and the the psychology of it is very
interesting i do think that
you know there are some who might just
write this off and say well okay yeah i
mean
you're sort of uh psychologizing
in some way um what may or may not
be an accurate psychoanalysis but
i think it can't be written off because
if we don't understand it we're going to
have a very difficult time dealing with
it and by the way merely understanding
it doesn't actually tell us how to deal
with it
but you know we talked about this a few
a month ago or so where you know we i i
explained that
to understand why they are willing to do
these things you have to understand that
a lot of these trump supporters believe
that they are at war they're at war
against the left and the media and
scientists
atheists communist marxists the
democrats who stole the election and on
and on
and in a sense they idealize violence as
well it's not just that they're
predisposed to it
they idealize violence as being implicit
as implying that they are also
courageous they're willing to take the
risk of going to the capitol and being
violent
and uh when you are at war a normal way
of interacting with the world
evaporates and you justify what you're
doing
much like you we see militaries justify
what absent
uh a theater of war would be completely
absurd immoral behavior
lying is obviously valid if you're at
war lying is no big deal
and what we saw on january 6 was that
even
property destruction violence storming
the capital insurrection
etc um even that is justified when you
have this belief
that you're at war and you share the
psychosis with the great leader so
there's a lot there and i encourage you
to check out the
the article and what you very quickly
realize is that
there are self-reinforcing aspects of
this that make it very difficult to
break people out of it very very
important thing to understand one of the
things we've been talking about in a
sort of hypothetical sense since the
riots
in washington dc on january 6th is
if instead of being a mostly white male
conservative crowd there
storming the capital fighting with
police pushing police with barriers
hitting police with fire extinguishers
and on and on and on
if it had been a black lives matter
protest if the political orientation had
been different or the racial makeup of
the people there had been different
would it have been allowed to go on for
as long as it did would it have been
handled in the same way and i think
intuitively most of us who understand
the way things have gone down in the
united states for the last many years
can only come to the conclusion that no
it would not have been the same
if the protests last week had been
different groups of people in terms of
their makeup
or politically oriented in a different
way
we don't just have to intuit
our sense of that because we actually
have a study about this and barack obama
shared this on his twitter account
recently
and the study was led was done by akled
acled
it's a data reporting project and it
looked
initially they used to look at armed
conflicts in african
countries and then they started looking
at the united states and in the united
states we've had so many
protests slash riots of different kinds
that there's plenty of
fodder and and data to look at
and what ack led found is that
law enforcement is much more likely to
try to shut down left wing
protests than they are right right-wing
protests
when law enforcement uses force to shut
them down
they are much more likely to use force
in the left-wing protests than in the
right-wing protests by a
51 to 34 margin
more than half the time when they decide
to shut down a left-wing protest they
use force
only about a third of the time when they
decide to shut down a right-wing protest
they use force and um there are
a number of different things to consider
here you might say well
maybe the left-wing protests are more
violent
and thus it makes sense that police
are more likely to try to shut them down
or to use force that is not
what the data actually shows the data
does not show
that left-wing protests are more violent
than right-wing
protests another consideration would be
where are the left-wing versus the
right-wing protest taking place
in other words political orientation of
the protest aside
are the left-wing protests happening in
places
whose police departments for other
reasons are more likely
to prevent them from going on too long
whereas the right-wing protests are
happening in places whose police
department
departments are more lacks in allowing
them to go on that also
does not appear to be the case and so
this is a really um a concept this is
not a trivial
thing uh and and where i believe
much of the investigation needs to be
is in the political orientation
not just of the police officers but
of the police departments and this also
includes
mayors we know that law enforcement is a
relatively conservative group
law enforcement in total supported trump
in 2020
at a much greater level than the average
population so
of course there are liberal police
departments and police departments with
liberal police chiefs or that work under
liberal mayors there's no doubt about
that
but overall the makeup of the officers
tends to be far more right-wing
than the average population this also
applies to the military although we did
see in 2020
that the military was more supportive of
joe biden
than they've been of of most past
democratic candidates at least going
back
a number of elections so certainly we
have to consider
whether the political orientation of the
officers
plays a role and also if you have
right right-wing officers but a more
centrist or center-left
police chief and mayor how does that
affect the handling of protesters
what we know is that when we talk about
the right to protest if the left-wing
protests
aren't more violent and we know that
they are not
but yet police are more like oh and the
left-wing protesters are not more likely
to be armed
and they are not then we have to say
well why is it
that the left-wing protests are more
likely to be shut down and is that
is that a restriction of speech and
we've seen
right-wingers either misunderstand or
pretend not to understand
when the first amendment is a factor you
know twitter suspending trump is not a
first amendment issue
it has nothing to do with the first
amendment we hear all the time
my first amendment rights my first
amendment rights trump's first amendment
rights when it has nothing to do with
the first amendment
but when you see a political discrepancy
in which protests are shut down along
the lines of the political orientation
or motivations of the protest by police
under the guidance of police chiefs city
councils mayors etc
you really actually have to start asking
questions about whether the government
is suppressing speech
and suppressing it along political lines
so
none of this is is a catch-all that
explains every circumstance but it's a
very good data analysis
538 has a write-up about it again the
the organization that did the analysis
is
acled a-c-l-e-d and we'll link
to the article about it in the
description on the youtube clip
for this story take a look at it let me
know what you think you can find me
on twitter at deepakman the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy
science they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that our program is mostly
funded by members who sign up at
joinpakman.com
you can use the coupon code better21
whose meaning should be pretty plain and
simple and obvious at this point
bettor21 will save you
a boatload off of a membership at
joinedpakman.com
so donald trump did something in public
yesterday leaving the white house
for his first public appearance since
the riotous
insurrection last week donald trump was
heading out from the white house
on route to the u.s mexico border in
texas to
tell predictable lies about the wall
that was never built
and that mexico did not pay for let's
get right into it donald trump
attempting to
rewrite history blaming other people
doing everything
we would expect at this point from this
deranged man
this was on his way out to texas
[Music]
so we're going to texas we're going to
the southern border
as you know we've completed the wall
they may want to expand it
we have the expansion underway it's been
tremendously successful far beyond what
anyone thought
we're stopping in large numbers the
drugs coming into the country for many
many years and decades
we completed the wall and they may want
to expand it
hold on a second that doesn't make sense
the promise was by the end of trump's
first term which is seven days from now
a wall across the entire u.s mexico
border
if you did that how would you expand it
would you go into the water it doesn't
really make sense and just lie after lie
after uncontrollable and easily
disprovable lie
let's continue as far as this is
concerned
we want no violence never violence we
want absolutely no violence and
on the impeachment it's really a
continuation
of the greatest witch hunt in the
history of politics
it's ridiculous it's absolutely
ridiculous
this impeachment is causing tremendous
anger
and you're doing it and it's really a
terrible thing that they're doing
now of course at this point trump saying
never violence
is silly it's saying you work
uh only with fire extinguishers not
matches
after you've already set fire to a house
and it has burned down
and then you say i'm a fire extinguisher
guy at this point forward of course i'm
a fire extinguisher guy
and again they want to put the
impeachment on democrats
democrats are divisive for considering
impeachment
trump did the thing that is impeachable
and as usual
the party of personal responsibility
taking no personal responsibility
whatsoever
never i mean donald trump is going to
leave office never
having taken responsibility for any of
his failures
and he just continues attacking
democrats
for nancy pelosi and chuck schumer to
continue on this path
i think it's causing tremendous danger
to our country
and it's causing tremendous anger i want
no violence thank you very much
once again impeachment causing anger
recent poll most people want trump
removed period we talked about that
earlier this week the anger is over what
donald trump did
and his supporters went into last
wednesday
already angry thanks to two months of
lies
told to them by donald trump and rudy
giuliani
and kaylee mcinanny and on and on lies
telling them joe biden stole this
election joe biden didn't really win
that's why they were angry and now to
say
democrats are causing anger give me a
break guys it's not even uh
it it's too ridiculous to even pass the
sniff test
and then that so that was trump on his
way out once trump landed in texas
again we heard from donald trump talking
to press there this time going after big
tech take a listen for our country
they're dividing and divisive
and they're showing something that i've
been predicting for a long time
i've been predicting it for a long time
and people didn't act on it
but i think big tech has made a terrible
mistake and very very bad for our
country
and that's leading others to do the same
thing
and it causes a lot of problems and a
lot of danger
so so far the people to blame right now
are democrats media
big tech still nothing from trump on the
riotous insurrection he incited last
week
in terms of taking any responsibility
when in reality that's where the primary
bulk of the responsibility is and once
again everybody but trump is to blame
you you might also notice that trump
glitches at the end of this next clip on
the word violence if you're watching
you'll
you'll again see that spasm-like thing
that we've seen throughout his
presidency
we still don't really know much about
that big mistake they shouldn't be doing
it
but there's always a counter move when
they do that i've never seen such anger
as i see right now and that's a terrible
thing terrible thing
and you have to always avoid violence
and we have
we have tremendous support we have
support
probably like nobody's ever seen before
always
have to avoid violence and then finally
donald trump asked about the capital
directly and the speech that he gave um
which said we're going to go down to the
capitol and here is donald trump's
answer
what is your role in what happened at
the capitol what is your personal report
so if you read my speech and many people
have done it and i've seen it both
in the papers and in the media on
television
it's been analyzed and people thought
that what i said was totally appropriate
and if you look at what other people
have said politicians at a high level
about the riots during the summer the
horrible riots in portland and seattle
and various other
other places that was a real problem
what they said
but they've analyzed my speech and my
words and my final paragraph
my final sentence and everybody to the
key thought it was totally appropriate
okay so the speech he refers to
is the one where he said half an hour
before the riot
let's walk down pennsylvania uh avenue
and go to the capitol
and we're going to fight and we'll never
give up and on and on and on that's the
speech he says was totally appropriate
um so effectively trump trying to
rewrite history
taking no responsibility for the riot he
caused
while blaming democrats and big tech for
causing the danger
that spee that's not a speech those
statements
are extraordinarily dangerous and trump
of course used the word
fight or fighting nearly two dozen times
during that speech that he says was fine
and he said at 12 30 let's go to the
capitol uh
45 minutes later the riotous
insurrection was starting now in the
meantime as i told you
yesterday the risk of even more violence
is huge
and so even these aside from it being
obviously dishonest and completely
ridiculous for the president to try to
rewrite history in this way
we're also not past the point of danger
according to an fbi bulletin
we talked about this yesterday armed
protests like the january sixth protest
are quote being planned at all 50 state
capitals
starting saturday uh through at least
january 20th and um
these these are tragic times and we are
almost done with trump
we're seven days away but there is the
real risk of more violence
over the next week and that's something
we all need to be paying attention to
as we speak and it may already have
happened by the time you listen to
today's show
the house of representatives is debating
in advance of voting and they may have
already voted by the time you listen to
this
about the second impeachment of donald
trump now you all know if you watch the
monday show
and or the tuesday show that i believe
impeachment
should not be a political calculation
but rather a responsibility
a duty that the house of representatives
has
question one float very simple flowchart
did the president do something worthy of
impeachment
if the answer is yes then you impeach
there are no other considerations
because it is
such an important responsibility placed
on congress
what is very interesting is that this
will not be
merely a partisan impeachment in the
house
we are hearing from more and more
republicans that they
are indeed going to vote to impeach they
may already have
depends on when you listen to this
congressman john
catko from new york was the first
republican to say
publicly he will vote to impeach donald
trump
over his role in inciting a violent mob
to storm the capital last week
he said he will join democrats today
when they vote to impeach trump for
willfully inciting violence
against the government of the united
states we then heard from liz cheney
from wyoming republican congresswoman
and daughter of former
republican vice president dick cheney
she will vote to impeach
today then we heard from republican
congressman adam
kinzinger that he will vote to impeach
saying uh that um it can what trump did
essentially cannot be ignored
period and uh this is starting to get
very very interesting we also heard from
republican congressman fred upton
that he will vote to impeach donald
trump
and that puts the number of republicans
that will be voting to impeach
trump at more than zero and that's what
matters now ultimately we will get
uh the full number we i i don't yet know
what it is as of this moment the vote
is likely happening or minutes from
taking place
uh but ultimately the real questions
are going to be in the senate and we are
going to talk about that in a little bit
i don't i don't want to
get ahead of myself but there is going
to be a real question as to whether
any republicans would be willing to vote
to convict in the senate and we will
get to that now um how much praise do
these republicans deserve in the house
for voting to impeach
very little that's that's the reality
the dominoes are falling and that's good
republicans are starting to jump ship
many of them many are not but many are
and to me this mostly is opportunistic
uh individuals trying to save themselves
that being said i still say keep them
coming
i still think again people should just
vote based on what happened
what happened is donald trump behaved in
an impeachable manner
and thus any vote to impeach is the
correct vote and that should be welcomed
but it's a lot easier to be the second
person to take a stand and second
applies in a number of ways here
this is the second impeachment of donald
trump
we have already seen some republicans
like
mitt romney and others distance from
donald trump
and it's always easier when your
participation is going to get less and
less attention
and the the second person to jump on
board gets less attention than the first
and the tenth gets less attention than
the second and that's the way
it goes and ultimately many of these
republicans are realizing there's simply
nothing to gain
and everything to lose from continuing
to side with a
seditious president i hate to be so
cynical about this
but this is republicans doing exactly
what we predicted they're just doing it
like a week sooner than we expected and
what i mean by that is
there was every indication for over a
year
certainly for months and you've heard me
talk about it every indication
that once trump is gone the republican
party both those who supported trump
and those who supported him publicly but
not privately
and those who started to distance from
trump publicly at a relatively earlier
stage
this was always the plan the plan was
always when trump is gone
to do a sort of on steroids version of
what they did with george w bush
remember george w bush did not campaign
with john mccain in 2008
george w bush was unpopular uh and
republicans made the calculation
it probably hurts john mccain to have
george w bush on the campaign trail
this is like a steroids version of that
where you are going to see
tons of republicans uh going to
pretending trump
i barely even remember that and i
certainly wasn't with it and
and going back to all of the things the
republican party has pretended to care
about
for a very long time we've got to reduce
the debt and the deficit
religious freedom lower taxes cut
business regulation
get in the way of so-called uh
government takeovers
by democrats and sometimes maybe they'll
call them communists and socialists etc
etc
um so this is not a surprise at all
it's simply happening a week to two
weeks
before trump leaves office we were more
leaning in the direction that it would
happen once trump is actually gone
that's it and they deserve no praise
they don't deserve to have
their uh reputations rehabilitated but
to the extent
that it's correct for them to vote to
impeach
i'm with it and after the break we are
going to talk about what's happening in
the senate
including multiple reports that mitch
mcconnell
is pleased with donald trump being
impeached a second time but what does
that mean
when mitch mcconnell says it the devil
is certainly in the detail so we'll have
more after the break
and also on our instagram which you can
find at david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpacman.com that's join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means
use the coupon code vote soon 18 all one
word
all lower case become a member today
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
there was very interesting breaking news
last night that the senate majority
leader mitch mcconnell who of course is
not just a republican but has been one
of the most
pernicious republicans to the causes of
sanity and reason for a long time and
has been very effective at getting
endless numbers of right-wing judges
confirmed successfully obstructed barack
obama's supreme court
nomination of merrick garland back in
2016.
that mitch mcconnell is reportedly
pleased
about donald trump being impeached a
second time
why because he believes it will make it
easier
for the republican party to purge
donald trump to wash its hands of an
association with donald trump
uh mitch mcconnell has told associates
this has been reported by the new york
times and confirmed by fox news so take
take your pick at this point
mitch mcconnell has told associates that
he does believe
donald trump committed impeachable
offenses
and that he is pleased that democrats
are going forward with a second
impeachment of the president
he believes it will make it easier to
purge trump from the party
and at the same time representative
kevin mccarthy of california
the minority leader and a big supporter
of donald trump
has reportedly been asking other
republicans
should i call on donald trump to resign
and mccarthy has been personally against
impeachment
and he said he and other party leaders
have decided not to lobby republicans to
vote
no and an aide to mccarthy said he's
open to a measure
censuring donald trump in private
mccarthy reached out to a leading house
democrat to see if the chamber would be
willing
to look at a censure vote instead of
impeachment nancy pelosi has since
ruled that out so this is these truly
are unique times in
american political history and when you
take this together mcconnell is pleased
that impeachment is moving forward
and mccarthy has been calling around
saying what about censure we're not
going to lobby for no votes on
impeachment what are we doing
um this reflects depending on your
perspective
a come to jesus moment for the
republican party
or political posturing and opportunism
now maybe you think i'm
cynical but i think the answer is
obvious
this is political opportunism and in
fact i don't believe that mcconnell is
having a change of heart
on uh on donald trump i believe
mcconnell
has had the same view on trump all along
and he said for as long as i can get
judges through
and block things democrats want to do
we'll sort of stand aside as donald
trump does what he does
here by the way is uh the the report i
read you is from
the new york times laura ingram on fox
news also saying they've confirmed
mcconnell
is not going to stand in the way of
impeachment and is quote done with
donald trump further fox news has
confirmed that
while he's not said whether he supports
conviction in the senate
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
uh is not going to stand in the way
of this impeachment effort instead to be
done with trump
now given all that and that ultimately
is the key
does mitch mcconnell support conviction
of donald trump
on impeachment will he vote to convict
when the senate takes up this second
impeachment of donald trump which just
minutes ago as we've been recording here
was walked over
by the house impeachment managers to the
united states
senate i don't know the answer to that
my instinct is probably not at the same
time mitch mcconnell's wife elaine chao
was one of the first to resign in last
week's
run of resignations she was donald
trump's transportation
secretary i believe that this is nothing
other than mitch mcconnell
doing what he likely planned to do for a
long time mitch mcconnell
has probably hated trump for a while but
like most republicans he was either
afraid of trump's cult
or calculating that it didn't make sense
to come out against trump to the extent
that he could keep
getting judges confirmed and get tax
reform done
and on and on and on and so i don't
think mcconnell
deserves any any any praise for this
um what he wants is for nancy pelosi's
name
and democrats to be attached in public
to this impeachment and he wants to hide
and figure out how he can use this to
his advantage to get this mess cleaned
up the mess being
the destruction that donald trump has
brought to the republican party
so there is no praise here for mitch
mcconnell
complicity due to being afraid is still
complicity
complicity or indifference due to
political opportunism
or self-aggrandizement or personal
benefit it's
all just as bad mitch mcconnell got his
judges
and now he wants to get rid of his old
baggage and
it may work unfortunately there is a
very short political memory in the
united states
we've already forgotten about things
that happened six months ago that
appeared to be really big deals at this
point and so the big narratives are what
matter
and the big narrative mitch mcconnell
wants is uh
i didn't stand in the way of impeachment
i used that second impeachment to try to
wash our hands of trump
i got my judges done we got our supreme
court justices and now let's get rid of
the baggage
none of them deserve to have their
reputations rehabilitated i've said that
a lot
and that is all that this ultimately is
and
where i get to in the end is what i
mentioned before will mitch mcconnell
vote to convict
in the impeachment trial of donald trump
in the senate i don't know the answer
maybe tomorrow i'll have some stronger
feelings about it
there is a stunning and hilarious
and pathetic and disturbing new report
from the new york times
about donald trump threatening mike
pence
with designating him as a [ __ ] and that
is a quote that is that is presidential
speech
here um mike pence and donald trump
had a falling out unlike any
that i recall seeing between a president
and vice president
donald trump we knew in the days leading
up to the january sixth counting of the
electoral votes and what became a
riotous insurrection in washington dc
had been pressuring mike pence to do it
do it do you know
take steal the election figure out a way
to do the right thing
and we have actually now learned
that donald trump specifically said to
mike pence in the lead-up
uh to that day early last week
quote you can either go down in history
as a patriot
wait for it or you can go down in
history
as a [ __ ] of course mike pence
mike pence is a dangerous ideologue
extremist
but he realized i can't steal the
election there
i don't have the power to steal the
election even if i wanted to steal the
election i couldn't do it
and very quickly as it became clear mike
pence was not going to stand in the way
and as the riotous insurrection grew on
wednesday afternoon
donald trump took to twitter before
twitter banned him and
said mike pence couldn't do it mike
pence couldn't do it
they then went up until monday without
even speaking despite the fact that mike
pence was put in physical danger
at the capitol by the riotous
insurrection that donald trump incited
and they reportedly had what is being
sort of
uh um i don't even know
vaguely described as a productive
meeting on monday unclear what the
relationship is between the two of them
so there's a few different things going
on here you know there
one of the things we have to be really
careful about
and we talk about reputation um is
framing normal behavior as heroic
or or virtuous because in comparison
so many people have been behaving like
absolute lunatics
and what i mean by that is lindsey
graham is an example we talked about
this earlier in the week
lindsey graham on very late wednesday
early thursday morning last week
spoke during the counting of the
electoral vote and he said things that
are just
the way it is lindsey graham said our
duty is just to count the votes
some of these objections are out of
scope
for the house and senate in a joint
session to really even deal with
things went to courts and courts made
decisions
and he was held up as a hero for like
six hours until then he said insane
things
the next morning and then also the
following night on fox news and
one of the problems is that we talk
about the overton window
and the value of pulling the overton
window to the left for example
to bring the center to the left to
mainstream progressive ideas
but there's another overton window
that's been absolutely brutalized during
the last four years and it relates to
hyper normalization
when you have a two-month campaign from
veritable lunatics
like donald trump and rudy giuliani and
sydney powell
and josh hawley and lynn wood you know
the full list of these people to insist
without evidence the election was stolen
stolen this that the other thing
when somebody simply says
this goes beyond the limits of what we
are allowed to do based
on our appointments here in the house
and senate
they seem so reasonable and people start
saying these are the good republicans
no lindsay was on tv the next night
begging for mercy for trump and saying
impeachment would be divisive well then
he should have thought of that when he
did something
worthy of impeachment that would have
been the time to think about it before
it became too late
so let's we're ending donald trump's
term
with something very similar to what i
said at the beginning of donald trump's
term
which is we must work hard and it's
really tough to avoid the hyper
normalization
when so much of what we see daily is
outrageous
when what we see every week would have
been a one one-year scandal for barack
obama had it happened then
it's very difficult not to see been
slightly less cartoonish but still not
benign right-wing radicals as being sort
of sensible
and you know when we say mitt romney
actually seems to be making some sense
we're not saying we agree with him
politically at least i'm not
we're not saying he's a friend of
progressives we're simply saying
he has been consistent on what are the
limits
of the house and senate and presidential
power etcetera i still disagree with him
on tax policy
i still disagree with him on a whole
bunch of other things
but at least he's been consistent
lindsey graham is not that
mike pence is not that mike pence was
limited
not by his delusions of grandeur we
don't know what he might have wanted to
do could he have gotten away with it
he was limited by the fact that he can't
actually do the thing donald trump was
asking him to do
and it's a very important thing to
remember as we get past
this administration and it gets into the
rear view mirror
and we think about it we want to
remember it for what it was it was hard
to fight the normalization while it was
going on
and we have to remember that we're gonna
have to work just as hard to fight it in
retrospect
and really remember just how insane it
was we will ultimately see what happens
with impeachment in the senate
but uh the the it is at the same time
extraordinary that a president denounced
his own vice president
but mike pence deserves no praise for
not doing the thing trump asked him to
do because in the end he couldn't do it
it simply is not something that he could
do make sure you're following us on
facebook at facebook.com
davidpakmanshow we will take a quick
break and be back with
much more right after this the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
slash david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
we've been following the investigation
that the fbi
and local law enforcement and other
agencies have been doing into the
riotous
insurrectionists from january 6th and
over the weekend and over the last
couple of days more and more people have
been getting arrested and booked and
we've seen the mug shots and we've seen
all of it but one of the questions has
been are they going to throw the book at
these folks what are the charges going
to be
is jail time prison time likely and we
got a little bit of insight into that
yesterday at a joint press conference
involving the justice department and the
fbi
where the latest data is that cases have
been
opened and many folks are going to be
facing some pretty serious charges of
the 170 people found so far
70 have been charged and that's expected
to grow
into the hundreds notably there are many
who will be facing charges of sedition
which carries up to 20 years in prison
here is video from the press conference
take a listen
we're looking at significant felony
cases tied to
sedition and conspiracy just yesterday
our office
organized a strike force of very senior
national security prosecutors
and public corruption prosecutors their
only marching orders from me are to
build seditious and conspiracy charges
related to the most heinous
acts that occurred in the capital and
these are significant charges that have
felonies with uh prison terms of 20 up
to 20 years
in addition to that we're looking in
taking a priority with
cases in which weapons were involved and
cases in which destructive devices were
involved as people know
through news reports there were pipe
bombs found outside the capitol the atf
is working on that
metro police is working on that fbi's
working on that to find that individual
or individuals
who planted those devices so
in addition to just those road cases
we're looking at we're going to focus on
the most significant charges as a
deterrent because
regardless of if it was just a trespass
in the capital
or if someone planted a pipe bomb you
will be charged and you will be found
so there's much to discuss here first of
all
just because they are seeking certain
charges
or even um filing certain charges
initially
tells us very little about how much
prison time if any
these individuals are going to do and
we're going to talk through that
now in the background of all of this is
another issue
which is that the question of murder
charges
also needs to be considered for those
involved in the deaths that took place
but we'll get to that sort of when when
we come to it i do think it's important
that we temper our expectations and i'll
give you an example of that
and i got a few emails from lawyers
about this my instinct was this and
then a few lawyers in the audience
emailed me about it
sedition is a very high bar to meet
in a court of law um and arguably for
good reason because it's an extremely
serious charge
it's essentially a crime against your
country in a way
and so i doubt we will see many sedition
convictions
if any the legal definition of sedition
is is precise and we'll look at it but
my expectation
is we're going to see people go down for
lesser charges
likely still federal charges many
with some prison time associated as well
but sedition is the act of inciting
revolter violence against the lawful
authority
with the this is the key part with the
goal
of destroying or overthrowing it this is
very much like perjury
and we've talked before about how
colloquially speaking perjury takes
place all the time during trials people
get up there and they say things that
aren't true
and and to some degree they know that
they're not true
but proving perjury because you need to
prove intent to deceive
is difficult and it doesn't happen very
often many
i don't know about most it's very common
that in a murder case
you have witnesses who say opposite
things and to some degree
they know that they they are unlikely to
be telling what they know to be the full
truth
but you don't see perjury charges you
you don't because it's very difficult to
prove
and a lot of work for prosecutors much
much like with sedition because the goal
of destroying or overthrowing the
authority
is part of the definition of sedition a
good lawyer and
some of these people are going to have
good lawyers many will not but some will
a good lawyer is going to be able to
defeat or at least
introduce significant doubt about
the intent of the actions
they will say maybe listen
they're on camera breaking the window or
doing this or doing this in nancy
pelosi's office or whatever the thing is
um but disturbing the piece
trespassing you know whatever but to
show
intent to overthrow is gonna be really
tough now some of these people were dumb
enough to post their intentions on
social media
and in those cases it will be more
difficult to overcome
but uh the point is uh you know law is
weird in that way
and there are good reasons for it in in
many cases
um but i think we should just be be
realistic about uh what what our
expectations
should be um the other the other thing
that sometimes
will happen is that events where
things are done as a group um
you might much more easily be able to
say
as a group this was seditious as a group
what this was was the attempted
overthrow of an authority
but that doesn't necessarily mean you
can apply that exact same intent and
agency to the individual person in a
court of law and to be clear
i'm talking only what we are expecting
to happen in a court of law
so the point is let's wait and see but
the good news so far is that the number
of people
uh charged is soon to get into the
hundred over 100 and it really should go
significantly higher
brian kilmeade a fox news host on fox
and friends
says democrats shouldn't pursue
impeachment against donald trump
which is happening by the way because it
might trigger republicans to do more
violence
this is saying let's negotiate with
terrorists that's what brian kilmeade is
saying here
let's take a look at the video and then
we will discuss
we believe that america could be more
effective and it's been ineffective
because we've been at each other's
throats what could be more disenchanting
they don't want to be around again they
don't want him to run again
they don't want him to run again that's
fine but you don't understand too
there's a lot of people that want him to
number one
continue to be a force in the republican
party believe a lot what he believes
he has 75 million supporters so if you
have an overarching sense that i got to
bring the country together
because we see what's happening around
this country how 50 state houses are
being
threatened on inauguration day this is
the last thing you want to do
it astounds me that now chuck schumer
guys
is exploring a possible work around
using the authority granted to two
senators
back in 2004 to reconvene the senate in
times of emergency
i assume this and have a quick
impeachment vote fantastic idea mitch
mcconnell has to sign off on it
but it would be as dumb as nancy pelosi
hopping on 60 minutes last night
and saying the president's an imminent
threat that's not going to happen
so suddenly the issue is oh there's been
so much political infighting
that is just hilarious but truly
brian kilmeade is saying negotiate
with terrorists the right thing to do is
impeach
but wait the terrorists will get violent
if you do it so don't impeach
only for that reason that's that's not
his phraseology but that's
essentially what he's saying it's the
equivalent of negotiating with
terrorists these are the people
killmead and his cronies on fox who are
always saying you don't negotiate
with terrorists the people they perceive
to be terrorists
if an action is correct if an action is
warranted
you do it you don't let people threaten
you with violence to get you to change
your actions
but because trumpists are likely to get
violent
if you impeach you skip impeachment
what brian what we're hearing from
trumpists
is we will respond with violence
if democrats use a power granted to them
by the constitution
that's more of a confession than a valid
political statement or
argument and what brian kilmeade should
be saying
is you know it would be really stupid
to go be violent and riot in 50 states
plus dc
again given how terribly that went for
the country
last week and given the fact that you'd
be rioting over the lies that trump has
been telling you which have no merit
50 or more court cases have found that
the lies that got you to riot
have no merit whatsoever so it's
we we've seen so much hypocrisy over the
last week and i know that hypocrisy
doesn't matter to the american right
anymore i know we
i've been here the last four years as
much as you have to the extent that
you've been here if there's any
three-year-olds in the audience then i i
take it back
um we saw this with business regulation
over the last week for
40 years i even had a tweet that i
should have uh i should have pulled up
here
um for the last 40 years i wrote
it's been deregulate everything from
republicans
let businesses do whatever they want
don't enforce antitrust
get government out of business and the
people's lives
and then all of a sudden republicans on
january 8th
regulate social media monitor
big tech break up monopolies
create new laws to control business
tell businesses exactly what to do and
when they can ban someone and not ban
someone and blah blah blah
and now the we will never negotiate with
terrorist crowd is saying
i don't know guys aside from whether
impeachment is correct
it'll make trumpists be violent again so
you shouldn't do it no
trump is the one who should have thought
of that before
he incited a riot on the tail end of two
months of telling people lies that they
fell for about the election
that's where the responsibility is
period and if
brian kilmeade really wanted to do
something good for the country he would
say to his audience guys
whatever happens with impeachment
whatever happens with the 25th amendment
don't riot don't riot because you're
rioting over something that is fake
trump has lied to you you've been
tricked you've been bamboozled you've
been deceived
don't go and riot that's not something i
expect to hear brian kilmeade say
uh anytime soon one question that's been
coming up more and more is could or
would donald trump pardon the capitol
hill rioters i got a voicemail about
that
if you want to leave me a voicemail you
can do so
at 219 to david
p here is a voicemail about the pardons
david although highly unlikely do you
believe that trump
could pardon the criminals of the recent
uh
siege on the capitol because you know
they're patriots
right and he's the law and order
president
question so certainly trump could do it
but he would need to know who they are
and
it's going to be a long process i'm
expecting it to take
beyond donald trump's uh last day in
office january 20th to figure out who
all the folks are
uh and even if they figure out who most
of the folks are figuring out what
charges are going to be filed so
i think in practical terms donald
trump's not going to be able to do it i
did hear from a lot of people who said
they should actually slow play the
investigation
specifically to prevent trump from being
able to pardon them
so trump could do it i think
logistically there will be challenges
because we're not going to know
uh all of the charges for a period of
time but bigger picture than that trump
is worried about himself
you have to remember trump doesn't care
about these people the people that
support trump mostly are people trump
has spent his life of privilege trying
to get away from
you know trump talks about the boaters
in the intercoastal in florida
he talks about the uh co-workers in west
virginia or whatever
trump has spent a life having people
uh keep him away from what he considers
to be that kind of riffraff
and so trump doesn't care about these
people and in fact there are reports
which are sort of sad
and also funny just because of it
exposes the things trump thinks about
trump was reportedly displeased that the
rioters last week
looked low class if you can imagine
trump
wanted the he would have preferred the
people riding
i guess to all have flown in on private
jets and only a couple of them actually
did
so trump doesn't care about these people
at all if he thought it was politically
advantageous he might try to
to pardon them but he's leaving office
it's over and so
trump's concerns are am i going to
pardon myself and would it hold up
legally
and he's been advised by some folks
around him not to pardon himself
and is he going to pardon his children
and his son-in-law and rudy giuliani and
whoever else that's what trump is
concerned with
and uh i am expecting we will see some
really wacky pardons
in the last seven days but i have no
expectation that donald trump is
actually going to try to pardon those
people because he doesn't care about the
writers
and in fact he didn't like their
appearance he thought that they they
seemed too lowbrow
we have a great bonus show for you today
another member of congress is now
positive after sheltering in place at
the capitol during the riotous
insurrection
many republicans refuse to wear masks
during that period of time
we will also talk about the future of
coronavirus coronavirus not expected to
go away even after everybody's
vaccinated
but its impact is going to be lessened
dramatically and we will talk about why
and more riot firings continue
more companies deciding whoa you were
involved with the violence in dc on
january 6th
this is not the right place for you to
work you're gone
so we will talk about that on the bonus
show as well
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpackman.com i'll see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman